my favorite time of the week every
wednesday it's
football pod in america and today
there's just three of us no mike tarico
no liam mchugh
i don't know whether or not they have
cramps that's not my department to try
to figure out but it is
coach tony dungey and rodney harrison
and we're going to take you through some
of the stories in the nfl good afternoon
gentlemen how are you today
doing well seems to be a good excuse for
missing yeah
well speaking of what ended up being the
game of the year due in part to lamar
jackson overcoming his bout with
cramps as we move forward after that
47-42 victory by baltimore they kept
their playoff
hopes alive who do you guys feel better
about between those two teams coach i'll
start with you
baltimore or cleveland who do you feel
better about
i think i might feel a little bit better
about cleveland
uh baltimore they had some injuries
maybe they get some of their guys back
that'll help their defense both sides
i'm worried about the defense when you
give up 40 plus points
that never makes me feel good but i saw
cleveland come back bounce back lamar
jackson's
obviously special but uh i i think
cleveland might be in better shape down
the road
coach i agree with you and i think kevin
stefanski he's done a wonderful job
working with baker mayfield
and we saw that the baker may feel that
we were waiting on
to come out there and compete lead his
team and i just thought he was
absolutely terrific so i give a lot of
props to
kevin stefanski really getting that
confidence back in baker mayfield mike
they have proven over the last couple of
games the browns have that they can
compete with the best teams around even
though the ravens have been struggling
they were desperate
and to give the ravens that kind of a
game on a night when the ravens were
essentially playing an early playoff
game was impressive
you couple that with the win over the
tennessee titans and i think the
cleveland browns are moving in the right
direction
and i wouldn't mind seeing a rematch of
the browns and the ravens
in the postseason we also may get guys a
rematch of the ravens
and the steelers in the postseason i
don't know how i feel about this one if
there's a round three because
i don't know how to feel about the
steelers right now coach
are they in trouble after losing two in
a row
i'm with you on that mike i don't like
where the steelers are right now
because i think they've lost their
identity for years and years and years
hey we're going to be physical we're
going to be tough on defense we're going
to pound the football and make big plays
in the passing game
the big plays have kind of vanished and
there's no running game
so when i see a steeler team that's
running 12 times 14 times they're
running for under 40 yards a game
i don't think that's a winning formula
in pittsburgh in january
and you look at you look on the
defensive side of the ball coach and you
know
you saw all those injuries and it was
evident that they're missing their guys
and
if they can't create pressure if they
can't create turnovers
we already know they can't run the ball
or at least they don't even attempt to
run the ball
it's all big bend so if big ben if he's
not
almost perfect then they're going to
struggle and they got some young guys
dealing with some confidence issues
mike tomlin has to get back to being
physical his personality running the
football
and getting these guys back on track and
you're right i don't know
go ahead i was gonna say defensively
when you take out your three top middle
linebackers
uh because of injury or vince williams
was gone because of covert but then
bud dupree your second best pass rusher
your best corner and joe hayden
it's tough to overcome come all that now
they'll get hayden back
hopefully uh they'll get splained back
but they've
had a lot of losses on that defense
and when you look at their schedule over
the past few weeks they were supposed to
play on thanksgiving it got postponed
three times before they ultimately
played it they had three games in 12
days they haven't had a normal week and
randy fickner the offensive coordinator
suggested when they have the benefit of
a normal week
maybe there'll be something on the
offense better than what we've seen but
coach
i don't understand what's going on
running game has been such a central
part of the pittsburgh offense for all
these years
i don't know whether or not they're
deliberately getting away from it
is it happening during the game is the
quarterback
audibling out of run plays this is
something that at some point you think
the head coach has to come in
and and like mo and the three stooges
clunk some heads together and get this
all figured out i thought we would
really see it in our game sunday night
marquise poncey the all-pro center was
back james connor was back
buffalo their achilles heel is run
defense if there was ever
time to be set up to run the football it
was sunday night
and we didn't see it we saw the
continuation of the short passing game
ton of passes very little running and
again that
is just not the formula to win in
pittsburgh and playoff weather and
playoff time
coach you just hit it it was coming out
my mouth you talk about the weather and
we saw how
pittsburgh when the weather was you know
the wind and the snow
and all those different things it
started to really affect big bend
so you know the weather is going to
continue to change especially in
pittsburgh
when they go on a road if they have once
they go on the road and have to go
whether they go to kansas city or
wherever they have to go they're going
to have to deal with the weather so
yeah that's a that's a big problem for
them they're going to have to make sure
they can run the football of the big
issues for the steelers offense has been
receivers dropping passes and i love the
perspective you guys bring to this
because we have a coach we have a former
player
so here's my question when you have this
issue with receivers
who despite these gloves that are so
great supposedly you never drop a pass
they're dropping pass after pass after
pass
coach what do you do to handle that
problem in your locker room and rodney
when you're a defensive back and you
know there's a receiver
who's got an issue dropping the football
how do you deal with him coach what do
you say
yeah well you really have to get it
going and
uh eric ebron he's had trouble with
drops his entire career in the nfl he
had trouble with drops in in
detroit and in kansas city uh deontay
johnson
it's something that's happening this
year these guys are trying to run with
it before they catch it they've got good
hands some guys are going to drop the
ball because
they don't have good hands but johnson
has good hands so it's a concentration
thing
you just have to work on it and you just
have to say that drops are not
acceptable we're not going to play you
if you drop the ball
coach you've heard of alligator arms and
that's what i see
these guys are coming across the middle
they want no part of coming across that
middle middle and catching the ball
especially a guy a little guy like
deontay johnson
but mike if i see a guy like kim i'm
walking up past him
you know during pre-game warm-ups and
saying you come across that middle i'ma
knock your head off i'm talking trash
remember about the drops i'm busting his
chops every chance i get to remind him
i'm reminding him hey what's up
butterfingers hey you got any oil on
those gloves i'm talking snack
well i talked to leslie frazier the
bill's defensive coordinator before the
game and he said that's all they worked
on it's
it's all short passing we're going to
make the tackles we got to come up and
be
physical and i'm sure they were saying
the same thing hey we're on you guys
and we know you're going to catch these
five yard routes and we're going to
blast you and and
i think you're right rodney that may be
what happened
and that's one of the points chris sims
has been making on the morning show he
says the steelers has become predictable
in their predictableness which i'm still
not sure is an actual word
but we've been using it because when you
know the pat that the passing game is
going to be
four and five yards the defensive backs
can get a head of steam and you know
you're going to get that hit as you try
to run with the ball and it may cause
you to have that
just enough of a lapse of concentration
coach that the ball comes out of your
hands
and that's that let me let me say this
real quick
i'm sorry coach real quick and you know
it's funny because when we played you
guys
and you guys had all those weapons we
felt like if we played man-to-man
coverage if we jammed you if we were
physical with you guys
we could get you in a situation where
the weather could be a factor
where then we could take away a lot of
the short intermediate routes
and then try to force you guys to throw
the ball down the field so i think
you're spot on with that mike
the steelers lost of course to the
buffalo bills which is nothing to be
ashamed of the bills have been playing
so well lately they're
probably in a position where they could
beat almost anyone rodney since you have
so many fans now in buffalo i'll start
with you
on this do you believe the bills are for
real
yeah trust me i i coach
how many weeks in a row did i talk
positive about the buffalo bills i
talked about leslie frazier
i talked about their secondary heck even
earlier in the year i talked about
jordan poyja and micah hyde being you
know one of the best safety tandems in
the national football league
but all of a sudden everybody jumps on
the bill's bandwagon i pitch
pick the pittsburgh steelers now they're
killing me bill's mafia but all i can
say is this coach
i just look at my two super bowl rings
and i'm just wondering when when the
buffalo bills catch up with
as many rings as i got i just don't know
when they can catch up
i'm not gonna answer that one but i was
the one that was a little hesitant
because early in the year it seemed like
when when buffalo had a chance when they
could prove it to me
they came up a little short you know
tennessee didn't have a practice week
and and beat them and the the rams it
was a
screwy fourth down past interference
that kind of led them off the hook in
that game
but lately they've been meeting the
challenges they've been meeting
the tests and i'm starting to believe in
the bills
you know they started off 4-0 and
everyone was feeling good about them
including themselves
they got hit in the mouth by the titans
followed up by the chiefs and i think
they got knocked wobbly and they started
to wonder where are we here
now that we get in december and they
have three games in prime time they have
that
that other game that's going to be
saturday afternoon on nfl network so
it's a national platform people get to
see what they can do and i feel like
they're rising to that moment
and coach isn't this the time of year
where you want a team to rise up and
show what it can do as you're getting
closer and closer to the playoffs
you want to be at your best in december
and i think they are they are peaking
but i still
go back to that tennessee game that
kansas city game
where boy it just didn't look like they
could compete with those teams
uh the rams they played well but you
know they they
won that one kind of in a flukey way uh
arizona they played well and lost in a
flukey way so
um i i think they're a very good team
i'm not quite sure if they're there yet
to be to be put with the
kansas city green bay new orleans just
quite yet
i you know i i think buffalo is a really
good team the thing that really and i
like what leslie frazier has done made
his team a defense a lot more aggressive
and
since he's allowed them to be aggressive
they're making plays they're playing
with confidence and even if they give up
a couple plays they never
panic and their inability to
consistently run the football
i think they have solid backs there's
nothing
really great about their running back
position
i think that's going to be something
where in the playoffs if they can't
consistently run the football now
everything goes back to josh allen he
feels like he has to do everything
and a lot of times if stefan digs if
he's double covered he's still giving
him opportunity so
i like buffalo buffalo's a tough team
josh allen is the real deal he's that
dude
but you know they still have some issues
that i'm concerned about
and the reality in the afc the chiefs
are clearly the dominant team and
everyone else is just trying to keep up
and maybe prove that they could upset
the chiefs in the postseason
in the nfc we never know what's going on
one week it's this team one week at sas
team then it's this team
where are we right now coach from your
perspective
who ranked the top three teams in the
nfc right now
you know i really am leaning towards the
rams because i think they're playing the
best defense
i like their defense their
aggressiveness they can run the football
uh rodney will point out to me i'm sure
that they're gonna get
inconsistent quarterback play from jared
goff when he's hot
they can beat anybody when he's off
obviously they struggle but they can run
the ball
and play defense green bay can score
they can run the ball they can throw it
their defense is up and down to me new
orleans i thought was the most balanced
team
but i see some cracks in their defense
and they they play sometimes they don't
concentrate
and that philadelphia game uh they gave
up a lot of yardage that shouldn't have
happened
uh right we were going to break down a
play and we didn't have time on sunday
night where
uh linebacker just goes the wrong way
all he's got to do is slide to
to his gap and it's a no game play he
goes
in the back door tries to make a big
play in the backfield and it's a 75-yard
touchdown pass i see that a little too
much
from the new orleans defense guys i look
at it this way and
with with everything that's happened
with kovitt and one team having a home
field advantage and everybody else has
to play
i look at green bay there's no way aaron
rodgers has given up that home field
advantage there's no way that number one
seed at his age
and how valuable to be able to rest and
not only just rest for that week
but to be able to have teams come in and
have to play in lambeau field you think
the green bay
you think the saints want to come out
from the dome
and play in that cold weather you think
the rams want to come and play in 20 or
10 degree weather they don't so to me
i understand you know the rams are
probably a more complete team if jared
goff is hot
that's fine drew brees is gonna come
back tayson hill is actually playing
well enough and it wasn't about taysom
hill
but he's playing well enough they could
have won that game it was more so the
defense
but yeah i just don't think anybody's
going to beat the packers for that
number one seat it's too valuable mike
the thing about when we get to the
postseason though we've seen this with
the packers we've seen it with the
saints they're prone to lapses when you
expect them to show up and play
well they just pick a day where for
whatever reason they're not ready to go
and when we think about all the the the
the things we've learned over the years
about
january football championship football
what are you here defense and running
game defense and running game and the
rams have the defense in the running
game and it may be like the 49ers
last year where they turn their
quarterback into bob griese
and minimize him and just ride coach the
defense in the running game and
and they if as cam acres has developed
into their new workhorse
they're less prone to having that lapse
where
you see one of those games like what
happened to them today if they're
relying on
aaron donald and company and cam akers
as the centerpiece of their offense
no i agree that that defense is legit
they will not go into any game
feeling like they have to score 30
points to win
and uh that that's a good feeling they
can win low scoring games
i just like the way they're playing i
think they're pretty complete
and you know just looking at the rams
defense too we always talk about aaron
donald aaron donald but it's not just
aaron donald i've been screaming at the
last few weeks of last month
it's not just aaron donald making plays
brockers and those guys
leonard floyd they're getting after the
quarterback they're making plays
jordan fuller's making plays on the back
end so i think this is a collective
group and and they're
you're right coach they're playing
extremely well but you know i still have
my reservations when it comes to jared
goff and if
if they want to go to the super bowl
it's not going to be just playing good
defense
and running the football he's going to
have to throw for 300 plus he's going to
have to make sure
you know three touchdowns no
interceptions he's going to have to have
really good games for them to advance
somebody from the nfc east is still
going to make it to the playoffs and
host a playoff game and the good news is
the nfc east teams have quietly gotten
better and we actually may see a team at
500 who knows
by the time we get through week 17. but
right
now who do we think is going to win that
division and i get the feeling that
so much of that is going to be driven by
who gets the best quarterback
play coach who do you think it's going
to be it really is
and i think washington right now i think
even dwayne haskins if he goes in the
way they're playing now
he doesn't have to do it all he doesn't
have to be great he just has to be
okay daniel jones is not healthy
and when he's not healthy that takes
away a lot of what he does
best so i i think the giants had a good
formula going
but they're struggling right now we'll
see them sunday night and see if
jones is a little bit better
philadelphia got very good
quarterback play last week and they
looked like a different team but i think
washington with their defense
their ability to run the ball uh and
whether it's alex smith or haskins
playing good football
i think they're the team to be see coach
i don't think i don't believe that you
can interchange these two quarterbacks i
just think that alex smith is a
different like he's on a different level
mentally
the way he the knowledge of the offense
and the trust level
you know when you put him back there
when you have haskins back there
eventually
he's going to have to make a play he's
going to have to step up and make plays
it's not like their offense is that good
where he doesn't have to do anything so
yeah the defense is really good the
front four they're creating turnovers
and they're doing things like that but
what happens if they don't if they're
not able to create a turnover
is haskins i don't believe in haskins i
just flat out don't
so if if if alex smith if he's able to
play
i trust him i believe he's going to take
care of the football i believe that each
week that he
plays he's building confidence through
with his injury and everything that's
going on
but with haskins he scares the living
crap out of me
and alex smith has so much experience
he's played in big games he knows what
it means he knows what the stakes are
and and he's just so happy to be back
after going through one of the worst
injuries we've ever seen
i continue to be fascinated though by
what the eagles have done
with jalen hurts because it was just a
week ago that longtime senator jason
kelsey came out
and essentially said it doesn't matter
because it's been a
failure of the entire offense players
coaches everyone so i'm thinking well
all we're going to find out is it's not
the quarterback's fault because jalen
hurts isn't going to be any better than
carson wentz and then he ends up being
tremendous and as i look at week 17 all
due respect to the giants
the eagles in washington play and i hope
that it comes down to that game
to determine the playoff spot because
that would be
even though the winner of the division
may be sub 500
that would be a great game coach to
determine who gets that home playoff
game and i'm not going to rule out
the winner of that game automatically uh
uh losing i'm not going to assume
they're automatically going to lose the
next week in the wild card round
i agree with you we saw what
philadelphia with a rejuvenated offense
did against new orleans who was supposed
to be the best team in the nfc and
i'll say this doug peterson called a
different game
sunday with jalen hurts in there and we
saw that during their super bowl run
carson wentz was playing very good
football but when nick foles went in
doug peterson tailored that offense to
nick foles they got the rpo
game and the things that foles did
really really well and they went all the
way to the super bowl
it seemed like this year for wince they
were just dialing up plays and
letting him make things happen but for
uh
for their rookie quarterback per hertz
they they structured some things we had
some zone reads some read options some
design
quarterback sweeps some roll out passes
where he was just
looking at one receiver and throwing the
ball or taking off running
and they did what he did best and i
think if he continues to do that that
offense will move
and the thing that stood out to me is
when miles sanders came out and he
talked about leadership
i mean this is jalen hurt's first start
he talked about the leadership
so it had to be such a great like
it had to be so big in that huddle as
far as his leadership for him to come
out and say that and as long as carson
wentz has been playing
guys have you ever heard of anybody come
out and talk about
carson's wentz leadership i didn't hear
that and it's so hard as a young
quarterback to get gain the trust and
the faith
of your teammates and the confidence of
your teammates so i just think that
jalen hurts moving forward
and it's going to be somewhat up and
down because he's still learning the
system and
they still have the same weapons that
they have but clearly when he's the
quarterback he's decisive
he's not intimidated the moment's not
too big and he is an
athlete he's a big athlete he's not
afraid and he sees the entire field it's
just a completely different
feel i know i know the eagles they're
sitting up there in their their little
fancy offices up top and they're trying
to figure out like what the heck are we
going to do because we blew it
because jalen hurts is going to be a lot
better quarterback than carson wentz i
think we can all see that
now speaking of the eagles and the team
they beat last week the saints that put
them in position where it's going to be
harder to get the number one seed and
their next challenge is the kansas city
chiefs coming to the dome
this weekend drew brees likely won't be
playing it'll be taysom hill again
with patrick mahomes in company and
look even though the saints are among
the best teams the nfc has to offer the
chiefs are still the chiefs coach do we
think that the saints
can get this victory or is this a
situation where
patrick mahomes and all the weapons he
has at his disposal once again do
whatever it takes like we've seen them
do week in and week out to get the win
well the interesting thing for me is
going to be chase mill and we praised
taysom hill and he really has done a
good job
but you have to remember a lot of those
games they're playing
and they're playing ahead uh if we get
17 points our defense is playing lights
out
that's all we need this is a game where
if their defense plays well they might
give up 27 points
so this is a game where that offense is
going to have to put up some points
there's going to be pressure to score
and i want to see how the whole offense
and jason hill respond
in that situation yeah i'm looking at
saints defense coordinator dennis allen
he did not have his team ready his
defense ready to play against jalen
hurts
and he's going to have to deal with all
these weapons he's going to have to deal
with
you know mahomes running around making
all these incredible throws so
i'm really looking forward to some
individual match-up like who matches up
with travis kelsey do you get chauncey
gardner-johnson
is it malcolm jenkins i just don't know
if they have enough in the secondary
so i'm looking at those guys up front
davenport they
rankings they have to sheldon ranks they
have to get after the quarterback and
cause
um pressure to patrick mahomes if
they're going to win this game
that's not easy to do with tyree kill
and travis kelsey it's not like he can
double both guys and they're both having
huge seasons and
coach like you said what it comes down
to is they're going to score their
points
you have to find a way to score more and
with taysom hill that's going to mean
throwing the ball more and we've seen
him develop as a passer
we know that he can run the ball they've
got plenty of weapons this is going to
challenge sean payton to be as creative
as he's ever been and he came out after
that loss to the eagles
and he said this is on me i didn't have
my guys ready to play you rarely
see sean payton not have his guys ready
to play in consecutive weeks coach
no they'll be ready to play obviously
for the chiefs they've had that game
circled for a long time
but the chiefs have lost one game in
almost
a little over a year and that was a game
where the raiders scored 40 points
so that to me is what's going to have to
happen shawn's going to have to get his
creative
hat going come up with some things move
the football
and have a 30 to 35 point game in order
to win
hey coach you know the one thing that he
has to do he has to stay patient with
the run game
i think alvin kamara had 11 touches um
in the run game and
that's just not enough you got to be
able to run the football and don't get
in this situation where you're trying
it's a personal you know pride thing
where you're trying to
just do something that you normally
don't do on offense run the football use
alvin kamara hit him in the flat
and force these guys to tackle on the
open field then you can negate
you know the pass rush and all these
guys you know all these different exotic
blitzes that
kansas city does but what happened
philadelphia got ahead
in that game philadelphia got a head and
i think
that's when sean kind of triggers hey we
got to score we got to catch up we got
to throw
and i could see that happening if kansas
city has a couple drives and they score
i could see the saints just going past
past pass and you're right that's not
the way to play kansas city
yeah that game's coming up late
afternoon and we've got the evening game
see you later dallas cowboys you've been
flexed out
browns and giants flexed in i can't wait
to watch the browns again after monday
night i'll put the browns in prime time
every week the way they've been playing
guys
it's been fun as always and thanks to
everyone out there for
uh some of your time today we'll see you
next time on pftpm and football pod in
america
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports